[Music]
and come on man news submitted by to be
ready Oh a husband and a wife for both
topless in their own home but she's
getting charged with lewdness well the
guy that's because they jiggle that's
cuz they do her windows open and people
soften he should get charged with lewd
first the [ __ ] off if you're looking at
my windows and I'm naked
that's all you that's what I'm saying
how you gonna like well how did that
phone call go 91911 how may I help you
there is a woman in her own house with
her husband and she is naked exactly
yeah you know we're gonna send the
police over right now man we're setting
up can you describe the woman yeah I
think she's gonna see tits know maybe
Dee's really hot body is there anybody
else present in the is she she forcing
herself upon anybody oh there's a man
and he's making out with her pretty good
yeah oh yeah he's got his tongue in
there pretty good
I mean is he topless as well Oh yep yep
that's his shirt off no I can't believe
she has her clothes off we're saying the
police look at that right now thank you
so much god bless you and God bless the
United States of America they're
touching nipples oh no hurry City Hall
Foreman Mormon land her naked your own
home disgusting how dare you with only
one of your wives sorry maybe it is one
of the wives it was one of the wives
calling the other line all right so this
28 year old woman was how many year old
28 okay she was putting like she was
installing fiberglass and naked in her
homes garage with her husband taught and
and so at one point like they just got
like fiberglass on them or whatever so
then they ended up like taking their
clothes off down to their underwear and
then at that point that's why it like
they're just like trying to get the
stuff off of their clothes fiberglass is
dangerous people yeah so then that at
that point is when her husband's
children saw her stepchildren aged 13 9
and 10 walked in I
wandered into the garage and so they
ended up seeing her like topless because
they they called the cops on their Oh
mom no that would be so this actually
happened back in 2016 and the mom like
the birth mom of these kids found out
about the situation years later and
reported it and now the stepmom is being
charged with three counts of lewd no and
so they're saying that she could
potentially be a sex sex registered sex
offender wait so you can't show your
titties to your own children I mean a
subject so if the stepchildren walked in
on the parents having sex right are
there are is reliable good they just saw
porn maybe I mean that was not
intentional it wasn't with the intent to
try duh
and then like the man like nothing
happens to the man because about all
it's because he's the biological dad is
that why but what he does responsible
man nipples are okay I guess they're
more than okay I mean we're but then why
on they're almost unwanted I mean but
can't you say he allowed it to happen
now he is a part of it he's party - yeah
he's guilt by association this is
Shannon
oh hell I don't want to see no titty
from that one that's the boy that's the
singing of my people okay I may be file
a police report
yeah I'm going to the FBI probably
there's no one using [ __ ] like logic
here I mean in Utah does logic exist
that's true I know are there rules
different every state is different is
that illegal I think one person in the
whole state I don't know if there's
logic in any state titties that belong
to somebody else if you're underage is
illegal I don't know they probably
doesn't funky ass laws out there Wow the
kids walked into the room right
years ago and they're not traumatized
but they're not crying I would have been
traumatized if I saw our titties let's
say let's say you're a doctor right
if you're adopted and then you have this
new non-biological parent that is your
official what's the word Guardian
guardian and she walks out of the room
naked like is that elude I see that
seems like that's repair it now no but
that seems more than them walking in by
accident if you are walking out knowing
you are wiring doubt that might be one
thing like I don't even think that's
wrong I didn't realize I didn't realize
how serious this situation is right if
you walk out and you're naked and you're
that translucent white that's like
almost like your ghostly apparition like
at that point that instills a level of
tear in you that I don't think is normal
it sounds like on some real [ __ ] lens
it's baby mama sounds real [ __ ] salty
she's trying to get revenge but isn't it
definition of lewd like sexualized and
more you know it's not like you're just
standing there naked but if she had
fiberglass one or nipple she kept
pitching it off in front of the cubic
tell me why the white the baby mama was
probably like the kids told the story
and then she's like you know what [ __ ]
that [ __ ] I went and tried to flip it
into the they knew that the kids were
coming out she took off her top in front
of the children and then she told them
to hold the shirt and then she jiggled
it like this she finished the
installation yeah and she made them
watch the chick looks like she would
dress up like cosplay at Comic Con Black
Widow and everyone's kind of like please
you don't have to do this yeah
from Avengers a character girls were in
the cosplay tend to look like that in my
opinion yeah unless hired by agencies I
think what were you hired were you a
beer chick I went um what's-her-name
from Watchmen along things yeah totally
but were you hired not from them I went
for a show AHA thank you but I would I
try I've been trying to get a costume
made Witchblade oh yeah of course the
comic books okay
they act like she went down and [ __ ]
motorboat of one of the kids a huge I
mean well it just
like 30 okay there needs to be like
legal core and then like some real [ __ ]
courts in real [ __ ] well the baby mama
sounds like a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah I
want to see what the baby mama looks
like and why did your relationship not
work out dude I want to know what kind
of I saw these for the wedding photos
because you probably have to lower that
like a lot if I have to keep on getting
that the white balance is all everything
how dare you beat everything's blown out
you got to kind of hold your thumb down
for a little while wait can we show them
again I'm so happy
titties like look oh she's got a million
eyes bugging painted but - Jess - my
friend Jess that girl black I mean look
at him this is a man that married a
woman that is a sex offender oh yeah
right
oh is that what they call Billie no no
well can we make it a thing well she is
it she is she might be right might be
registered sex offender makes ten years
I can make it hey Nikki babes you know
how you make of litter cuz she robbed
those kids of their childhood she's a
certified thank you see that's why I
look for you like help me I got you I'm
trying to give you something yeah but
yeah so they're saying that it's a class
a mr. book uh that's [ __ ] crazy I
wouldn't want to know no bars like why
don't you get a puss
was that not an option this is the
highest I can get like what's the most
he has to be explained for like 45
minutes why there is no age he's like
okay okay so [ __ ] you okay a lot of
conversations huh yeah
I get it now I get it out you got a
Class C misdemeanor [ __ ] Bart's mom a
bust out to start beating the [ __ ] out
of her
C's get degrees not in that household
yeah mm-hmm you know so do you think if
this you think this mom should just go
up to the first moment beat her ass
facts on sight
that's a vengeful ass [ __ ] dude first
time if I'm going to jail already you
might as well be worth it oh man you got
that type of thinking I can't even think
good for you man first off if you're
gonna tell me that I went did this have
you ever beat somebody though and you're
like that wasn't satisfying enough then
you just go in fine I don't know I've
never had that Nikki but you remind me
of a friend of mine he is he's your
whole last name I know my friend I have
a friend who has a talent he says that
he could make a weapon out of anything
around him if any [ __ ] ever went out oh
and I feel that you have a similar my
dad taught me to know all your exits and
to always be prepared in case [ __ ] goes
down am I good or am I good okay if you
are going to go to jail when you were in
jail go ahead and explain that to
somebody that you're in there because
your titties were out in front of your
stepchildren and their baby mama was the
one that went in snitched you wanna baby
she give like a little more details cuz
it sounds like you should be in jail for
thank you does that not sound but if I
beat her ass because she accused me of
all these everyone's got a band in a cup
on the jello sell like the story man and
when I'm locked up you all know why did
you beat up the baby mama facts on site
[ __ ] you better not if you have the
balls to go and report me that means you
want to die
if the baby is there what do you do what
if the baby's there cover your eyes
that's my that's what this month you
don't want to see this baby
you take your t-shirt off you tied over
their head it's not gonna stop me from
doing this if you don't want these
problems one get sugar gets the bra
[Laughter]
mommy mommy it is again and she's like
and don't tell us all about this because
it gets people [ __ ] up later oh I know
but I don't know so they are still gonna
they're gonna wait so exposing kids to
teaches is it's [ __ ] up that's why Tet
as equals sexual is nuts to me that's
crazy
just saying that it's because they're
there it's sexual I'm a friend like when
she came to go visit me when I gave
birth to Isaac and I was breastfeeding
him she literally asked me is that
turning you on I'm like what is wrong
with it she's bad horny you what you're
not a horny friend she she literally
asked me this okay so equals cycle so
she said later after I said what the
[ __ ] are you talking about she's I can't
say get really turned on what she was
confiding in you she was like I could
trust you with anything
I'm leaving never answered her yeah I
did I answered her and I said what the
[ __ ] are you talking about okay now what
if physically probably got her a
question now what if he took off his
pants and his penis was out while he was
trying to dust off the fiberglass and
they walked in that's jiggly so
therefore it is indeed anything jiggly
anything jiggly that's my rule so in it
so when you go into school to be a
lawyer and Steve City has Joe Mallya I
have Steve city and Steve City if it
jiggles get it out of here okay giggles
or Wiggles but when it dips on it
doesn't jiggle no it does not a court
sort of waves so it's okay then
so flattened girls are okay fat girls
are completely protected
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]